you're on your way to work driving
enjoying the freedom and flexibility
your car provides you but then bam
traffic jam you inch forward on the
congested four-lane road for a good 20
minutes thinking about how the problem
of traffic could be solved well of
course by adding more lanes if the road
is full you widen the road simple common
sense the city leadership agrees the
road is wide into six lanes and for a
few weeks or months traffic flows better
but then bam traffic jam again the road
is widened again this time to eight
lanes and for a few weeks or months
traffic flows better but then bam
traffic jam yet again what on earth is
going on how come the road always fills
up regardless of how many lanes we add
this phenomenon is called induced demand
first observed in the us in the 1930s
and our politicians have been pretending
it doesn't exist ever since let's take
this four lane road connecting the
suburb with the city center people in
that suburb can either take the bike the
train or the bus to the city or they can
drive and many do thus the road is
clogged the slowness of car traffic
motivates people to see alternatives
though like the bike the bus or the
train once the road is widened to eight
lanes people find that driving is faster
now and people keep switching to their
cars to take advantage of this until the
road fills up again and korchafik
becomes slow and the vicious cycle
starts anew okay so why don't you try
building so much road capacity that it
will never be fall wouldn't that solve
traffic no especially around large
cities there simply isn't enough
physical space to build enough lanes to
accommodate every potential driver for
example the kt freeway in texas widened
to now 26 lanes still gets clogged up we
will not solve traffic by widening roads
just like we won't solve obesity by
loosening our belts by widening the road
instead of solving traffic you only get
to choose how many lanes of traffic jam
you want so what is the solution to
traffic easy turns out induced demand
also works in reverse the less capacity
he wrote has the more people opt for
alternatives if lane reductions are
coupled with investments into bike lanes
and public transit bam suddenly traffic
gets a lot less severe less being late
from work less finite life wasted
standing bumper to bumper less noise
less pollution and safer adjacent
streets for children and pets take a
look at this iconic picture of the katy
freeway assuming an average u.s car
occupancy of 1.5 per vehicle every
single person in this picture would fit
inside two of these shuttler double
decker commuter trains i know because i
counted now tell me as a taxpayer would
you rather pay for the maintenance of a
two-track rail line or 26 lanes of road
answers on a postcard especially if
you're watching this from the us next
time someone tells you public transit is
communism or something remember as a
european taxpayer i pay for this as an
american taxpayer you pay for this as
the saying goes a developed country is
not where everyone drives a car it's
where nobody needs a car to get around
you